البدايه اليوم لكره القدم وجنونها تهديد
ووعيد مؤكد واجهته رابطه المشجعين
المتشددين او التراس في المنتخب
الارجنتيني لاي لاعب يتسبب باصابه النجم
ليونيل ميسي قبل بدء مونديال 20 22
الالتراس الارجنتيني اكد في بيان انه من
يتعمد اصابه ميسي قبل المونديال سيكون في
خطر الاطراف قالوا في بيانه من ميسي هو
الوحيد القادر على تحقيقه حلم المونديال
الغائب عن خزائن فريق التانجو نحو سبعه 37
عاما ويعد المونديال القادم الاخير لان
نجم الارجنتيني الذي يعمل في تحقيقه حلم
الظفر بالبطوله العالميه الاغلاق خصوصا
وانه سيلعب اخر مونديال له مع بلوغه السن
الخامسه والثلاثين المزيد عن تاريخ تهديد
اللاعيبه
تحديد اللاعبين ليس جديدا في كره القدم
ووصل احيانا لنهايات ماساويه فقبل نحو 28
عاما كان اللاعب الكولومبي الراحل اندرياس
اسكوبار على موعد مع عده رصاصات غادره
خرجت من عناصر في المافيا الكولومبيه
اثراء تسببه بهدف في مرمى بلاده خرج على
اثره المنتخب من كاس العالم امريكا عام
1994 وايضا في كولومبيا تلقى لاعب وسط
المنتخب كارلوس سانشيز تهديدات بالقتل عقب
تسببه في ضربه جزاء ضد المنتخب والخساره
امام اليابان لكن الشرطه تدخلت لحمايته
وعدم تكرار الماساه عدوى التهديد انتقلت
لاوروبا فها هو لاعب منتخب الدنمارك
نيكولا جون يتعرض لتهديد بعد اهداره لضربه
جزاء امام كرواتيا للخروج من كاس العالم
النجم الاسباني سيرجيو راموس كان قد تعرض
لعده تهديدات بالقتل بعد اصابته لمنتخب
لكابتن منتخب مصر محمد صلاح في نهائي دوري
ابطال اوروبا عام 2018
[موسيقى]
من بيروت الاعلام الرياض
نورنا اليوم صباح العربيه
شكرا
صباح الخير لكل عم يتواصلوا معنا ويتشدونا
اهلا بك تحيه رياضيه يا جورج الحدث الابرز
والاهم عالميا قادم المونديال وجنون كره
القدم كيف يمكن تفسير اليوم ظاهره تهديد
اللاعبين جماهيريا
يعني التقرير الولد من من لحظات بيفسر كل
شيء وعطا ممثلين كثير كثير كبار واحد منهم
ادى الى الحارس للاعب اسكوبار عام 1994
بمباراه فريق كولومبيا ومنتخب امريكا
بس همم يعني بالفتره الاخيره ما عم نشوفها
تهديد عن بيوصل لحد الخطوره
بال 2018
بتاع الحياه هم ضحيه العنف الجماهير
العائد للهوس الكروي لو نتحدث ما اصل هذه
الروح العنيفه يا جورج
هذه روحي اكثر شيء موجود بامريكا الجنوبيه
ان هناك همم كره القدم هو هو دين بالنسبه
لالم يعني اهم شيء اليوم يعني اذا رحنا
على البرازيل اذا رحنا على الارجنتين قال
يعني المتنفس الاساسي للشعب هناك كره
القدم عشان هيك تشوف الناس مهوسه كثير
بالفوتبول ومهوسي ومتعلق كثير من
اللاعبيننا
عندهم حلم دائما انه المونديال او الفوز
او الفوز بالبطولات حتى بتصير هناك بس
يعني كاس ليبرتادوريس بين الفرق اللي
بتجمع بين همم البرازيل الارجنتين
وكولومبيا وغيره وغيره بتشوف حضور جماهيري
والصوت الجماهيري غريب بعيد عن اوروبا
هناك صخر كبير هناك حماس كبير بالملعب
وهذا الشيء بعود الى التعلق الجمهور بها
اللعب همم الى حد الهوى وشفنا شو صار من
همم من احداث يعني واليوم مثلا بالارجنتين
ميسي مطالب يرجع يعيد ويكرر انجاس دييغو
ارماندو مارادونا الاخير بعام 1986 وقياده
الارجنتين الى الفوز بكاس العالم وهذا
الشيء بشكل ضغط كثير كبير مع النجم الكبير
طيب يقال ان الكثير من هذا النوع من
الجماهير جورج اما مافيا او مراهنين على
المباريات ما رايك بذلك
كثير الفتره الاخيره في اموال كبيره عم
تندفع
لكره القدم والمريهان عن مباريات كره
القدم همم بس يعني اذا زعلنا مراهنين ما
بعرف قد ايه صحيح انا اقدر اكثر من الناس
اذا كان كل المهووس بعالم
همم على غيرنين ذكرت بعد همم
مراهنين مراهنين ومافيا
مافيا
مافيا يعني موجوده ببعض الدول صحيح
الناس المهووسين بكره القدم تابعين الى
المافيات مثلا اكيد الشخص الي قتل اسكوبار
1994 بتصور تابع لمجموعه مجموعه مجموعه
كثير طيب السؤال اليوم يا جورج في ظل كل
هذه الظروف هل يتمتع جميع اللاعبين حول
العالم بحمايه كافيه لمنع
النجوم النجوم منهم يعني مش
مشيب بودي جارد حواليه ويكون
يحط له ايضا مرافقين يعني مثلا بطريقه
خاصه لنيمار
بين اللاعبين ما بتصور راح يكون فيها
الامن الموجود حولين يعني النادي بيهتم
دائما بالنجوم تبعه وعلى اللعب انه هو
كمان بروح ينتبه بس انا هلا في في دول
اوروبا طبعا حلقات خطيره يعني همم بس
تهديدي على مثلا تعرضوا له همم
محبي ميسي
في الدوري الفرنسي او غير لاعب بيحاول
يسيبه لميسي او او يعرضوا للاذى راح يكون
مهدد همم بالقتل
شكرا لك